they wanna you wanna hug you wanna hurt
yourself i'm not a republican
i'm republican and uncle sam hog
time for another edition of change my
mind where we sit down for hopefully
productive conversations on
controversial topics and uh hear from
you in the comments section
now sometimes it's hard to find voices
of opposition willing to engage in
conversations so
this week we reserved a booth at the
texas state democratic convention
and that sets the stage for this
edition's premise america is superior to
all of the countries
changed my mind we also saw some
familiar faces
who became friends and they might
surprise you hey danielle how are you
good to see you good to see you danielle
i don't i don't look as as polished as
you i'll give you that right away i've
already had my chance at your table
i'm going to give others a chance i
appreciate it glad to see you danielle
now
for this topic this isn't just lip
service i genuinely believe the united
states to be the greatest country on
earth
what you're about to see are three
people who tried to change my mind what
was your name
marilyn mays marilyn mays stephen
crowder nice to meet you nice to meet
you stephen so
i just i just want to make sure that
just to recap here i said i believe the
united states is still the greatest
country in the world superior to all
other
countries in my opinion you're welcome
to change my mind and you said
last week maybe but this week an
all-time low what do you mean
this week last last week and even this
week we're at all time low
okay you know i'm just so
exhausted over these children these
toddlers being taken
yeah and i need you to help me
understand
why we would take babies and
toddlers because in the work i do
it looks to me like since the russians
won't give us babies
they're going to take the little
children that just came here and adopt
them out
since the who won't give us babies
russians you know the deal fell through
in trump towers
that's what you think it was about
that's a joke yeah all right well it
matters before we get
because you're obviously aware of
trump's exec trump's executive order now
i am okay so now they're not going to be
separated they're going to be detained
together so is that progress
as of this morning they still are well
yeah it takes a while but
are you happier about that i was i was
really happy about it
and then when i saw the loopholes the
loophole that right after
you know that that last paragraph at the
very end
not paragraph the last phrase at the
very end and i went same stuff different
day
yeah and then melania's jacket
yeah well let me ask you though so this
has been a week that obviously you
disagree with some you know the obama
and clinton policies the flora's
consent policy so your problem isn't
with trump it's with the clintons and
obama's but
um let me ask you this does that change
do you disagree
with the premise that the united states
is the greatest country in the world
that it's superior to all other
countries
or is it just that you're a little worn
down from the newsweek
i think we're falling in stature i think
that i mean we we've been following i've
been upset since g7 okay
i've been falling apart since g7 because
how would we do our allies like that
this man is just
dismantling america the respected we
have
i can remember last year and the year
before born on cruises
and pete just being having them
apologize
for this country i've never had to
apologize for my country
i'm a veteran i don't understand thank
you for your service
and you know it's like i'm up here
having apologize for what
because people say for trump how so
because he's a humiliation he's an
embarrassment he don't know the king's
english
okay he cannot hold a decent
conversation
i don't believe he went to wharton
school of business i think somebody else
took his test
he is ignorant because you know a lot of
people would send folks to take their
tests back in the day
yeah i had a guy who actually he would
do that when he would weigh in for
wrestling practice he had a twin brother
and they would wait he would his brother
would weigh in but let me ask you i get
that you're not a fan of donald trump
and there are a lot of things that i'm
not a fan of is either but
i probably support more policies of his
than you do but not all of them
um but again i want to go back to the
premise today is the united states is
the greatest country in the world
uh what do you apologize people for how
do you believe we're inferior to other
countries or what country do you believe
is better than the united states
i feel like like
great britain and france and canada
i feel like those countries are making
us
i mean are taking the high road and i
feel like
everything i believed in is slipping
away from me
and i've just been distraught these past
two weeks but everything i believed in
when i first fell apart is the night
when i realized about eight o'clock that
evening that trump was gonna win
and i thought okay i'm gonna work with
him you know because he's my
commander-in-chief i'm gonna try to get
with him
i appreciate that but then he just kept
being more and more ignorant man stop
you from
yes really quickly so i don't want to
interrupt but i want to make sure that
we this keeps falling off if you see it
i know this is you don't want to see
what's under here no jawline
um so you mentioned canada britain and
france so you believe they're better
than the united states let me ask you
this you said everything you believe in
is disappearing
uh you're a veteran um did you serve to
protect freedom of speech
i did so what about the fact that those
countries don't have freedom of speech
only the united states does but you know
what
that's not what i see right now you know
you only you only get caught up in what
you see
no no no no no it doesn't matter what
you see as far as when i was there well
no but
we haven't constantly constitutionally
enshrined here in canada
the uk france people are jailed for
speech for offensive things
or fined that doesn't happen in the
united states we have a constitutional
right to freedom of speech they
don't so wouldn't you say that the
united states
certainly as a veteran if you're serving
to protect freedom of speech is superior
to those countries
if only because we're the only country
with freedom of speech but it
why i'm so distraught it looks like
we're getting ready to lose
it i mean anyway he's playing footsie
with with uh
with with kim and putin and you know
applauding kim for wiping out three
generals the day before he came and
you know his people sit up you know when
i see that i get nervous because it
looks like
if nobody puts that dude in check we're
going to lose
everything and it's just i'm just sad
well i understand that you're sad and
i'm sorry
i don't want to see anyone sad that
you're feeling this way but i'm hearing
a lot of how you feel but i don't think
that's really objective reality freedom
of speech is
actually not being eroded here like it
is no not
unless the left unless the democrats
would have their way they support hate
speech laws
republicans are the ones who've defended
against it on campus they're the ones
banning points of view
because they're because they're
connected well you might need to read
some
might need to put some conservative
sites in your bookmarks so you can read
both sides because
i'm an ardent defender of freedom of
speech and as a matter of fact i've had
people try to silence me
people here who for i feel like we've
had a good conversation people
here at this very er this very
convention who threatened to firebomb me
slash my tires
just for me speaking out no because
they're liberals
i'm a liberal i would never do that to
you well then take it up with them
i would never do that to you well thank
you very much see we're more closer
friends than me and then no
yeah i mean i mean i feel like everybody
has a right to say what they want to say
but it's like when you start being
offensive and hurting people
you know that's when i started getting
nervous but but it's still protected
that's why that's why just not in the
country as you mentioned
and so it's like it's like everything i
believed in is slipping but does that
would you say that this is some progress
in our conversation it seems to me i'm
not suggesting all that you're ignorant
i'm canadian so i'm very aware
no but the point is you suggested these
other countries it doesn't seem like you
were totally aware that they don't have
freedom of speech i wasn't
so does that change your opinion no
you'd want to live in a you think a
country with no freedom of speech is
superior to the united states
see that would be just where we disagree
i think they're inferior with no freedom
of speech
i just think that we have a pig for
president and he's making us look bad
all over the world he's ignorant
and i just wish that he would
you know i know he is who he is and he
deserves to be who he is
but it just is so everything that i
thought of that a president ought to be
he's not and he's so rude and crude
around the edges and he's
well i'll tell you what i say this
respectfully because i still respect him
as a president
but for me i mean i felt that way about
president barack obama i felt as though
he didn't think he was born in wherever
that was trump lied about did you
what was that no i don't think he was
born in kenya no no no no no
i just think he was a terrible president
but i respect the office and i think i
respect that you feel that way
to king's english and he knew the law
this dude don't know nothing
i mean he's i don't even think he's a
good businessman yeah bankruptcy
we have record low unemployment record
high job participation
we're doing very well what a wages
they're growing really well we have the
highest
as a matter of fact do you are you
surprised to learn that the united
states has the highest wages in the
world
average income not surprised about that
okay so that's a good thing
about that and that's a very good thing
and i'm happy about that but
my thing is okay trump you didn't marry
american
trump you didn't um um you've got
all those immigrants working for you
most of the people that work for trump
yeah but there's a difference between
legal and illegal immigrants but i know
it but what about americans
i mean you you so pro-american let's
let's see
americans with most of these jobs and i
know it's all these jobs that americans
don't want to do
i know that i get that but it's just
that
i'm just i appreciate you taking that
i'm sorry to see you sad i
was can i give you one piece of advice
don't play so much so much
credence in one man you know i mean
you're you're responsible for your own
happiness it's not the state it's not
the government
do you have a family just destroyed
everything but you have a family
i love my folks you have a good family
yes focus on your family and focus on
your health
i do think even though i didn't like
barack obama i did notice a lot of
people right were so miserable and i
thought everything was over listen
it's one man we have safeguards in this
country
it's one man in the freedom caucus but
my point is you can still choose to be
happy i don't hate you
i don't hate you and i'm a conservative
republican i'm very happy to meet
somebody like you
and some of my good friends are
republicans you know and we agree to
disagree
it's just that this was a bad two weeks
yeah i can understand how it would be
rough for you
you know babies you know the work i do i
represent children as their guardian
and i see what it does when you move a
child and i know the parents are at
fault for bringing them here
and i know that people don't want to
clinton for signing the policy and obama
then for doubling back and not enforcing
it
exactly and so i realized that if
you've got to pay to play in the world
and sometimes you've got to invest money
in these other countries to keep them at
home
and i know that that's a problem okay
that's the first thing i learned in
political sciences sometimes you got to
pay to play
and if you're not willing to invest in
keeping those folk at home
and that's another monster because if we
get off into that our soldiers get
killed and it's another big ole miss
so i'm just saying oh i'm sorry well
thank you for taking
who want to you want to hug you want a
hug
and uncle sam hog well thank you so much
for taking this speak well
me that's okay hey listen i get it there
are a lot of republicans who are jerks
but i appreciate you taking the time
you're a good republican
i'm conservative libertarian
conservative okay
yeah so if you see someone trying to
firebomb this booth tell them to stop
i'm gonna tell them don't do it because
you're a reasonable man
thank you very much i appreciate it i
don't believe you've lied about anything
i try not to is a liar well i think
that's politics
politicians in general i know but not
every other word come on man
help me with that i pray for you i can't
even pray for him
i appreciate that i pray for him every
day you know what i pray for him and i
pray for barack obama as well i think we
share a lot of common ground
i don't want him to be like me i pray
for him to be who he is
but he's just so destructive in my eyes
and i realized that we were we were
raised under different circumstances
you know we come from a different world
but i just
okay i guess you could be more like jeb
bush
that's all i'm saying i don't think jeb
bush wishes he could be more like jeb
bush he's such a wiener
but all right well thank you i mean my
republican didn't win
okay and i but that's not why i'm upset
you know right
my republican didn't win well thank you
i don't want to keep you all down we
have to keep the chair for other people
but thank you so much for taking the
time
thank you for being a good conservative
thank you very much thank you for being
so pleasant and respectful i appreciate
it
thank you is this yours is this ours
this is ours
okay it's ours thank you apologies thank
you sir god bless you
bye bye
that was great
[Music]
what was your name by the way dianne i'm
stephen hi stephen
you are democrat i am not no i'm not
i'm i'm a canadian american dual citizen
conservative
libertarian to be specific yeah
this country has just gone down the
drain
how so well look what's happening donald
trump is the most
despicable i don't even have words or
adjectives
to describe this man and to see what
he's done and knowing what i came from
and how i saw my country deteriorate
under corrupt african rule which it did
unfortunately i mean there's no getting
away from it oh no i understand leaving
in their droves
it's still terrible today with their
their laws and farmers
what they're doing to the farmers and
you know i see it's not in so much of
farmers it's
just the whole infrastructure of the
country has disintegrated and my family
all live there
sure i've lived here for 20 years and
i've had
reasonable opportunities you know my
daughter's been able to go to college
which she would have done in south
africa anyhow
um
i cannot begin to tell you
how angry i am
with white spanish
republicans who are are not even looking
at the other side of the slate and are
now
that's why i'm here learning what this
man is doing
condoning it i mean who tears children
apart well
first off do you disagree with the
fundamental fundamental premise that the
united states
is the best country in the world you
don't disagree with that i i disagree
with the jesus okay so what examples of
countries would you say are superior to
the united states i guess to start
before we get to how much you dislike
trump and i understand that
korea they've gotten south korea south
korea they've got an incredible standard
of education
the highest in the world we don't have a
very we have one of the lowest
standards of education we don't have it
we don't have a great public education
system
terrible terrible yeah one one moment
one moment hey jared
let me you need to be the one to let me
know okay sorry okay so south korea
okay that's that's one issue is
education the other the other thing that
i feel very very
uh angry about at the moment but it's
been there always in this country
there's a lot of hatred and divisiveness
that trump
literally scratched the surface of it's
always been there because
i've felt it as an immigrant people have
told me to go back to south africa
if i didn't like it here so it's not the
greatest country in the world well those
are individual examples they're
anecdotal people being rude i mean my
mom's french canadian
yes i was right i'm canadian was raising
canada my whole life so dual citizen
that doesn't change the empirical data
the evidence as far as now let me let
somebody sort of present
that let me present why i think it's the
greatest country in the world
is that uh you know freedom equal
opportunity
the ability to pursue happiness and in
south korea do they have freedom what's
free speech like in south korea
they're allowed to speak freely and what
about europe europe
a country like holland i've lived in a
lot of places freedom of speech doesn't
exist in those countries
in holland it is not constitutionally
enshrined
there are hate speech laws where you can
be jailed or fined for saying something
offensive
in every country you've mentioned they
do not have freedom of speech i think
hate speech crimes
are actually acceptable
i think that freedom of speech the first
amendment is to defend precisely
offensive speech it's not happening here
now
what's not happening here now because we
are not allowed to speak out
and we're attacked and the press is
attacked will be
fake news so is that is that
total freedom of speech no it's not sure
i'm talking about people being fined or
put in jail by the government for
speaking out offensively
it could get to that point it could be
but we aren't and
they are at those other countries you've
mentioned is that not important
i don't think that happened it doesn't
happen in south africa it certainly
doesn't happen in south africa you can
say what you like now
and it's actually totally acceptable so
in south africa
freedom of speech is a constitutionally
enshrined right yes
yes it has how do you know
it's not a constitutionally enshrined
right in south africa don't have a
constitution that follows what
the american constitution does but
basically people can speak out
i want to i'm not talking about
basically i'm talking in canada
basically people could speak out until
he started saying the wrong thing
and here's the thing i want you to be
able to speak out and say whatever you
want about president trump
i think absolutely whatever you want to
say my point is i would protect your
right to say
anything and so these other countries
that you name they don't have the same
constitutional freedoms that we have
but is our constitution such a great
constitution yes i'm glad you think so
oh if you don't think second amendment i
think is the most
archaic and the most ridiculous
part of a constitution that went back to
the 18th
17th century what are gun laws like in
south africa
very strict and you know no gun crime
right
very little compared to what's going on
here
very little very little crime in south
africa compared to the united states
there's no mass shooting
people do not go into schools and kill
students it's never
never happened okay it may be one-on-one
and it's happening yes with the farmers
but it's gangs
crime is far greater in south africa and
you also can't protect yourself against
tyrannical governments
so i would actually argue that south
africa is a precise reason for the
second amendment so we don't have a
government like
south africa as you just mentioned but i
appreciate you taking that i don't think
we're gonna find a ton of common ground
there if you don't
like the constitution but it sounds to
me like you might prefer these countries
i would i actually am having second
thoughts about i've been here 20 years
and i'm having taken thoughts about
living here anymore oh i i wouldn't
discourage you from doing that's not me
saying get out that's me saying if you
think that they're better countries
and you're not a supporter of the first
or second amendment you might be happier
in one of these other countries
thank you very much i appreciate you
taking the time
[Music]
now your your premise is america is
superior to any other country yes could
you please
yeah move your chair in there yeah so
let me give you my premise i believe
yeah it's the best
best country in the world yeah that's
that's pretty simple i believe it's the
greatest country in the world okay
and uh yeah i know you said you thought
you really changed my mind well i
i don't think uh the united states is is
the best or greatest country in the
world
okay i think there are a lot of very
good countries to live in
and i would mention the ones in europe
uh maybe japan
i think japan's a good country singapore
is a good country
australia canada
a lot of these are anglo countries
obviously yeah because
they all are the benefits have the
benefits of the british
history sure now let me get to specifics
um our country is perhaps the most
capitalist
sure or free enterprise country on the
planet
and i think that's a major problem okay
for this reason
to survive
free enterprise companies have to
continue to grow
they're always competing and if they
if they if they don't grow
they will lose market share
to other companies and they will
um uh then um
you can't hear so gung-ho saying you're
going to change my mind yeah i guess i'm
not doing it very well
i'm not interrupted you or anything okay
no you haven't sure you have you haven't
is there there's no water in here for me
sorry well you know just because
it's a it's a legal thing where if i
give you water and then you go and say
oh i feel faint
okay got it got it yeah okay so
uh we have we have uh a problem with
that because
uh as they lose their business in
competition
they will eventually go bankrupt and
that that company will then end
and uh they will lose all the employees
will lose their jobs
and have to fend for themselves now
that's one problem the other problem is
that as the population of the earth
increases which it has been doing
corporations have to continue to grow
to keep market share to keep the steady
market share because
the market share is going up
population's increasing so their
consumers are increasing
and uh when that happens uh they use
more and more resources
and a lot of resources are in short
supply
and more and more resources will
continue to
to uh disappear i believe you believe
this is exclusive to the united states
uh no but i think the united states is
one of the worst offenders now there's
probably a worse offender that's china
right in that in that respect yeah
they're using resources at an enormous
rate but you named some countries you
said in europe
uh canada i'm not mistaken would you put
that at the top of your list
i would put it even at least even with
the u.s maybe better
i would just european countries germany
france so any countries that you would
say are superior to the united states
since my
premise is possibly superior but at
least equal equal
okay and if they're equal that negates
your proposition which america is the
greatest or the best
okay what's that no we're good okay
sorry am i pretty sure looking at me
here
do they have the same kinds of freedoms
in those countries uh yes
they they are representative democracies
like our country
uh many people consider representative
democracy to be the best
what about freedom of speech uh yes of
course no they don't
they don't they don't japan great
britain canada
nope are you sure about that it is not a
concept scandinavia
norway finland many of these well i
notice you're mentioning very
homogenous countries so not a big fan of
diversity i'm guessing that's nice
uh that's true they they are but but no
let me clarify no
no it's not a protected right in canada
in japan
certainly not in europe you can be
jailed fined or many people are for
saying something offensive
so to me right away before we get to the
economics of it right we're the number
one economy we have the highest wage in
the industrialized world
before we get to that number one i told
you on my list was freedom
freedom equal opportunity pursuit of
happiness
freedom of speech doesn't exist in any
of those countries that's because that
was a unique founding of our country
that's a big part of why i believe we're
superior to those countries i'm not sure
i believe that
i think absolutely some of the now those
countries don't have freedom of speech
in a constitution
but they have laws protecting speech no
they don't people are jailed and fined
all the time in canada for example we've
had comedian mike ward on our show
who was put before human rights tribunal
for uh for a joke stephen barcelo a
pastor who was fined and jailed
you have a man who was jailed in the uk
for doing a karaoke version of kung fu
fighting and was considered racist
you have dank uh uh dankdog the pug who
was taught to do a nazi salute
as a as a joke there the list goes on
and on i feel like giving you enough
specifics nazi salutes and nazi prop
nazis a pug did a little nazi salute
yeah
the pug yeah anything counting nazis is
certainly banned in germany and austria
for instance
i'm aware of this this is in the uk and
that is it was a man whose dog did the
nazi salute
which let's admit listen i hate nazis
that's kind of funny for a pug who did
it while watching the show
and this man was put before a trial the
point is freedom of speech doesn't exist
in those countries does that change your
opinion at all
well again you're making a statement
that i'm not sure of
i i don't i i i know that in germany and
austria
using anything having anything to do
with nazis such as insignia
or song they can't sing the horse vessel
song in germany right since
uh so there are restrictions on speech
in those countries and that means
uh they're not as free as the us where
you can go out and sing the horse vessel
song if you want and
things like that of course i would never
do that i would never do that but do you
support their right to do it
of course okay that's if i didn't
realize uh
other countries what about blasphemy uh
we could be blasphemous in this country
yes uh
is it blasphemy legal in britain
i have no idea if blasphemy specifically
is allowed i know that it's actually a
hate crime to speak out against the
quran and specifically
muslims in canada and that's right i
would never say they're better countries
than the us
oh no then you you can't change my mind
then
i'm i'm saying say muslim countries no
i'm saying actually
in many of these countries people are
tried for hate crimes for speaking out
against islam
so that they do have blasphemy laws i
know for that for example you mean in
the countries i named canada yes britain
germany france yes
i really don't think so okay so let's
for the sake of exercise
right yeah let's say i'm not lying to
you after we do this you can i actually
have as you can reference these if you
want to
um and i've lived it uh let's say that's
true
would that eliminate any of those
countries from being superior to the
united states
if they don't have freedom of speech if
they don't afford that singular right to
their citizens that
that would certainly diminish them in my
opinion as far as freedom is concerned
because freedom of speech is obviously a
big freedom that we paramount that we
enjoyed in this country we enjoy it in
this country
i'm a conservative but i i absolutely
support every i i
hope everyone here speaks out as loudly
as proudly as they possibly can
and i don't even care if it's offensive
i don't care if it's rude i believe it
should be protected and i
i agree with that i am i'm a liberal and
i'm against um
uh speech restrictions on some
university campuses
thank you i think yes i know i i i'm a
when i was
a student at michigan university
michigan are you from michigan
well no i'm not i was born in detroit
but raised in montreal but
my dad went to u of m well i went to ann
arbor and i um
i was uh program chairman for our for my
house
for for a year and i one of the guys i
got was a
john birch society guy okay and we
treated him respectfully and i
i did too i thought everything he said
was nonsense but we listened
and i thank you i don't mind that i
think people might be against that today
let's say berkeley or some other
universities that would be prohibited or
something
so yeah i'm in i'm for favor uh if i'm
in favor
of freedom of speech and i and i i do
agree that conservatives shouldn't
uh be restricted as they often are
now um and that includes uh let's say
white supremacists and racists
however um they they should and a lot of
them have been denied
speaking however uh they should be able
to do that
under under in a controlled condition
where where
um secure their security if they want to
host i'm not a white supremacist or not
i want to make sure you understand yeah
i know that uh okay good
i probably tipped up by me hugging the
the black lady earlier
um but uh that being said if they want
to host their own private event and
speak yeah
yeah i i think they should have the
right to do so just like i think someone
should uh
but yeah if you say freedom of speech is
more restricted in those countries i
named
canada britain it's not iranian france
it is not a right
that would diminish them as far as best
or equal oh to the us look at that we
found some common ground can i get a
high five
we both agree freedom of speech is
important however
there's other things i mentioned the
economic situation
i think these other countries have a
better balance between uh
capitalism and socialism you know our
country has a mixed economy
we have true we have market market free
enterprise
but it's regulated and we have a great
a great deal of social uh programs
and um like social security and medicare
and medicaid that balance is found in
these other countries too they they also
have free enterprise
to a certain extent but they also have
the social programs i think the us
is lesser than those countries because
its social programs
are not as good as say great britain and
france and germany which have better
health care for instance in canada
incorrect well i i really think they're
better than our
yes correct okay well say what you want
i will just i have to make sure that i
understand
we disagree with first off at this point
you're now just saying in that facet
they're superior with the social
programs because they both agree
they can have all the social programs if
they don't afford freedom of speech they
cannot be a better country and i think
um i think these these countries are
better in that regard
just in that regard yes okay in that
regard yes right and i would i would say
that's a pretty significant difference
well i would disagree
so uh the the only as a matter of fact
the standard when people say that
socialized healthcare is better it comes
to a subjective
poll when people are asked if they're
satisfied with their healthcare that's
how michael moore said cuban healthcare
was better than american healthcare
remember in sicko everyone's parenting
that for years
canadian health care europe you look at
the mortality rates they're much higher
you look at the wait times they're much
higher uh of course not to mention we
have the highest wage
in the industrialized world outside of
luxembourg a country of 600 000 people
so we have higher wages higher standards
i would disagree with that
we do a lot of european countries have
have good wages on average for their
people
the most statistically the united states
has the highest wage in the world
outside of luxembourg
per capita per capita highest wage
highest wage
okay number one economy highest wage and
here's something else to consider right
i'm from canada right i was raised in
canada oh okay okay uh if the united
states wanted to take over canada
what time is it right now you have a
watch what time is it it's uh 3 12 3 12.
by 4 12 they could take canada right
yeah yeah we agree on that yeah you
couldn't you know let's do it we have a
few guys in propeller plan
yes uh uh and i love canada for a lot of
a lot of different reasons but certainly
i would not say it's uh anywhere near
the equal the united states um
and not healthcare in all facets but
that one too as well but hold on one
second let me let me finish what i'm
saying
um let's change one thing canada you
have to protect your own borders go
europe go sweden go the united states
foots the bill you can look at what's
paid into nato so
not only do we have better when you look
at objective parameters for health care
i'll get to that again in a second
specifically with canada
but we also innovate more there's more
medical research here there's more
clinical trials more drugs coming out of
here than anywhere in the world not to
mention we provide national security for
the entire industrialized free world
if you remove that all of a sudden
people can't have the same kind of
social welfare programs now
on scientific research the amount our
government spends on scientific research
has been decreasing over the years
and con in the contrary to that there's
more in the private i'm talking about
this private space we do more in the
private space
not only the government space but more
in the private space than any of the
countries it's not even close
i can't disagree with that right and
that's a good thing right it benefits
those countries
yeah we do do more private research
right well it benefits subsidizes their
social life
the companies mostly and there's a
secondary benefit to the population of
the united states
for jobs because it creates jobs right
yeah but that they wouldn't be able to
have socialized healthcare if not for us
innovating and creating modern medicine
now and then as far as so you take that
you go okay i'm starting to see a little
bit of a different picture
the wages are lower for example in
canada overall uh highest marginal tax
rate in my province of quebec i think is
about 52
um and it was actually wait times were
so bad
in canada in quebec there's a supreme
court case in 2006 i believe show we
versus quebec
there was a doctor actually taking cash
to provide patients with care and you
weren't allowed to do that at the time
and he was put out of business
and the supreme court said it's a
violation of human rights to not allow
people to pay for privatized care in the
face of
death in these waiting lines and now
they lie privatized they allow
privatized care in canada
so they're going our way they're
actually allowing for more privatization
because it's a disaster they're allowing
more private decisions yeah it was
declared it was a violation of human
rights to force someone
into socialized health care and that's
perfectly okay with me
i think that's an improvement however as
far as overall health care for
all the population uh canada and
and great britain and germany and france
are better because
we have great health care for the
wealthy for the upper middle class
even even the lower middle class but for
working class and poor people
our health care system is really bad
it's still better in those countries you
mentioned as far as survival rates
as far as uh treatment of terminal
illnesses oh yes it is i think the
statistics
would disagree with you read i've read
statistics people are happier
they have lower they have lower infant
they no i'm not that's just one idea
they have lower infant mortality they
have they don't they have
better health statistics in terms of
cholesterol
things like that than our country so
their health care system is working
better
and in that regard also they have better
uh social security systems ours is you
know just
you're just hanging on in those other
countries the european countries japan
great britain canada they they uh have a
better
what you what you call social safety net
social safety net yeah social safety net
yeah again they have a lot more free
money to spend when we flip the bill for
security the united states didn't put
the bill security wise but that being
said for
the objective parameters that is true we
pay
we you know our our military what is it
we pay more for
for defense than the top 15 other
countries combined
yeah we contribute more to nato than
anyone else that's not even close that's
true too they're not upholding their end
of the bargaining so if if
i know i agree with that i agree with
that they're not paying the percentage
of their gdp that they should
some are moving up now to that they're
spending it on social safety net trump
has
has uh started to threaten them isn't
that a good thing
well uh i don't you want to reduce the
military-industrial complex and force
everyone else to be able to protect
themselves i don't think they should be
paying their share
okay i'm aware of that you're a very
reasonable person i appreciate it even
though we disagree this is
well i think we agree on a lot of
specifics
yeah i'm just i'm just worried about
your major premise but it seems like we
agree with the problem
i no i think uh if i was a german
i think a german would say my country is
just as good as the u.s
he'd have the reasons and and a canadian
would have the reasons
uh i really i really think so i don't
think they have any reasons and to go
back to the one thing healthcare as you
mentioned by the way i will agree with
you
social security you're awfully good no
i'm not social security is a disaster
you know like medicare medicaid i would
agree with you our social programs here
are not very good
uh and i i also don't think they're very
good in canada uh i don't think they're
good across the board i don't think
they're ever as good as privatized
but you mentioned them as sort of a
blended economy you mentioned medicare
social security and i would say
those are examples of abysmal failures
which we agree with they're not very
good
um as far as you know healthcare again
this is very interesting you said people
are happier
well people were happier in cuba with
their healthcare in the united states
that doesn't mean it's better healthcare
people were happier in venezuela four
years ago i didn't think they knew the
alternative
that's the point there we go the
alternative is far better here we were
subjected to censorship
censorship of information press
censorship
educational assistance i hate to cut
this short but i actually do have to go
to an event here
coming up what was your name again sir
stephen stevens i'm steven as well
stephen crowder thank you so much
stephen hey i really i really hope you
follow this productive and
good civil discussion i really enjoyed
your company
thank you stephen hey there youtube here
if you liked this video watch another
one of our videos or subscribe hit the
notification bell those don't really
mean anything anymore today in youtube i
would say
hit a like with a thumbs up but that
might be gone or comment below but that
most likely will be censored so bookmark
the page of course if you're using
google chrome they'll find a way to [ __ ]
with your bookmarks so just
join up at loudearthcrider.com that's
that with credit.com
club you get a hand-etched mug and you
get access to the full daily one-hour
show
and you're not beholden to susan
wojcicki clint howard